Guten morgen.
Ich habe gehört du bist computerspezialist sehr renommiert.
Ja ich kämpfe gegen schwachstellen im internet.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertneununddreißig frisch auf den tisch vom vierten april zwanzig zwanzig direkt live aus der krise und ja,
was hast du so zu tun du tänzelst mal wieder auf der fernseher herum.
Ja also erstmal habe ich vor allem sehr viele e-mails zu beantworten und sachen anzugucken aber ich habe kurz bei markus lanz zu gast um ein bisschen über contact tracing zu reden also korona apple rein.
Da war es ja schon mal glaube ich oder.
Ja da war ich war ich schon mal zu gast ja da ging es um die hacking und dox geschichten mit politikern und journalistinnen der veranlagung zwanzig neunzehn glaube ich der fall.
Und was war diesmal anders.
Sehr viel weniger leute da.
Also die sendung findet ohne publikum statt es gibt natürlich dann auch entsprechende abstandsregelung was hier irgendwie auf der bühne ich weiß nicht genau ob die stühle da weiter auseinander stehen aber ich denke schon weil die.
Sich auf drei gäste vor ort festgelegt haben und dann weitere gäste nur per fernsehzeitung.
Annehmen ist ja schon sehr sehr gespenstisch andererseits auch also man kann auch sehen dass es seine vorteile hat ja du hast,
manchmal wünscht man sich einerseits ein bisschen feedback vom publikum oder auch mal so wenn ein gast zu ende behandelt wurde mal so einen applaus oder so ja andererseits nimmt das ein bisschen diesen,
dieser applaus jagt aus aus dem gespräch heraus hat halt also vor und nachteile.
Für die für die art der auseinandersetzung da aber es war schon insgesamt sehr gespenstisch ich bin dann am abend zurück gefahren mit dem zug
also konnten wir unter den gästen halt dann überlegen wer welchen waggon haben möchte ne also.
Wo war die aufnahme.
Das in hamburg.
In hamburg ok und dann hast du deinen eigenen wagen.
Konntest du deinen eigenen wagen wagen dir quasi wählen ich habe beim einsteigen zu dem schaffner gesagt oder wie wie die heißen zugbegleiter oder,
oder ich weiß nicht wie die heißen so gesagt so reservierung muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht genau darauf achten sagt er.
Nee nee.
Ja ist schon alles sehr sehr gespenstisch.
Was heißt auch das fernsehstudio ist jetzt mehr in so einer podcast situation gefangen orientiert sich alles richtung podcast so.
Ja ja ja ja klar ne und.
Podcast gibt den takt vor und der rest passt sich jetzt den gepflogenheiten an.
Ja
Können wir jetzt einiges wir könnten ja applaus einspielen hier zwischendurch wenn wir unsere thesen bringen das wäre doch mal.
Also ich finde das eigentlich schon also so ein so ein applaus button wäre schön.
Ok ich arbeite dran.
Du hattest auch mal ich glaube ich erinnere das ist viele jahre her da hattest du bei.
Bei raum zeit aus irgendwelchen gründen also es war ein fehler,
quasi da hattest du nämlich eine dein chapter marketing was du damals benutzt hast ich weiß nicht ob das heute noch benutzt das war eine mini spur und aus irgendwelchen gründen hattest du raum zeit so gerändert dass diese mittelspur ein so ein ganz leichtes tonsignal war,
kannst du dich daran erinnern.
Wer es war so ein kapitel gong der dann beim rendern mit übernommen wurde genau.
Fand ich eigentlich total gut ich fand das ganz gut weil man so merkt es ah okay der neuer gedankengang oder so ne.
Das stimmt da habe ich auch tatsächlich darüber nachgedacht sowas generell so ich meine so ein trainer ist ja in dem sinne gar nichts neues das machen ja auch manche in ihren
podcast gerade wenn du so monologisch unterwegs bist oder episode isch da magazin artig alles zusammen wirft dann sind natürlich so kurze akustische trainer ganz gut
da ja
hat sich nicht so richtig durchgesetzt der gedanke aber wäre an sich auch ganz gut weil es ja auch an alle andere so ein signal ist dass das sozusagen und jetzt neues thema und jetzt bitte mit nicht mehr zu dem alten quatsch.
Ja man will ja auch vor allem gar nicht so einen klaren marker für seine werbung im podcast haben.
Kommen wir zum zum feedback.
Wollte.
Wir haben wir haben das feedback also es gab relativ viel feedback zur zum corona contact tracing das fließt gleich in das update dazu ein deswegen behandeln wir jetzt erstmal feedback zum kapital zu der sendung davor.
Daniel kröger zu gast hatten.
Richtig weil da konnten wir jetzt in der letzten sendung nicht drauf eingehen weil die recht kurzfristig zusammengestellt wurde und wir wollten uns da eigentlich auch konzentrieren ja los geht's mit einem kommentar von loony tag.
Ein weit verbreitetes argument derer die kapitaleinkünfte dufte finden ist es dass dieses kapital ja erarbeitet wurde und dann hier erträge bringt,
empirisch ist das aber nicht zu halten denn ein großer teil des geldes das auf dem kapitalmarkt eingesetzt wird ist nicht das übriggebliebene ersparte des fließbandarbeiter s,
sondern der übrig gebliebene ertrag aus dem letzten kapital geschäft sie auch piketty das kapital im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert.
Ja tatsächlich also dazu nur meine anmerkungen gibt auch noch weitere kommentare die sich damit auseinandersetzen dass ich sage okay kapital erträge aussetzen auch die die.
Am vermieter hätten sich da immer wieder zu wort ne nochmal,
es geht wenn ich sage mieten auszusetzen natürlich auch darum dass potentielle,
vermieter die noch kredite abzuzahlen haben ebenso von von diesem,
kapital erträgen freigestellt werden weil das erscheint mir eben dass das eigentlich zugrundeliegende problem zu sein das hier,
er arbeitete einkünfte plötzlich auf null gehen ein kapital eben nicht und das ist ein grundsätzliches phänomen dieser krise gibt's auch diesen tweet der die ganze zeit kursiert von einem vermieter der das erkannt hat.
Und seinen mieterinnen schreibt es kann nicht sein dass diese gesamte welt in krise ist und das einzige der einzige wirtschaftszweig der vollkommen davon unbeeindruckt ist.
Der der vermietung ist und wenn das nämlich so ist dann heißt es eben auch dass vermietung eben ein spezifischer.
Faktor dieser krise ist nämlich der einzige der noch bleibt wenn alle anderen erträge weg sind.
Und das sieht man insbesondere in diesem einzelhandel insbesondere bei den gastronomien die wir besprochen haben da ist miete,
das ist der eine faktor der eine faktor der denn gerade,
probleme macht und zumindest in berlin muss man ja sagen weißt du es ist ja nicht so als würden die vermieter dann ohne einkünfte dastehen die können ja als kleine einzelunternehmer.
Problemlos sich dann die fünftausend euro sofort sicherung von der investitionsbank berlin holen und dann tut es auch nicht ganz so weh.
Zweiter kommentar von konrad etwas länger.
Ich will mal versuchen etwas zum thema staatsanleihen und eurobonds grade zu rücken meine these falls wir mit den klassischen instrumenten der finanzkrise von zweitausendacht auch auf diese krise antworten,
kommt es zu einer umverteilung von unten nach oben in einem nicht vorstellbar ausmaß.
Richtig ist dass staatsanleihen die negativ verzinst werden hauptsächlich von pensionsfonds versicherungen et cetera von mir aus auch kirchen und dem verein um die ecke gekauft werden.
Diese organisation dauerhaft liquide sein müssen und größere kursschwankungen nicht ausgleichen können.
Nun verwalten pensionsfonds die gelder der normalen bevölkerung welche durch negativzinsen enteignet wird oder wer das wort nicht mag geld verliert,
gleichzeitig gibt es rentner die gerade aktien etcetera welche ihnen über jahre von staatlicher seite und den medien angepriesen wurden verkaufen müssen,
und unternehmensleiter pleiten.
Auf der anderen seite gibt es einen kleinen teil der bevölkerung der finanziell flexibel ist und in den nächsten monaten oder jahren auf shoppingtour geht das heißt immobilien aktien und gesamte unternehmen aufkauft.
Hinzu kommen noch hedgefonds die vorher den kursverfall an den börsen beschleunigt haben und sogenannte aktivistische investoren diese können zugleich billig schulden aufnehmen um beim anlauf der wirtschaft wieder voll gehebelt nach oben dabei zu sein.
Ein letzter aspekt bezüglich der corona und eurobonds ist zudem das absehbar ist dass es hierfür nicht genug private oder institutionelle käufer gibt.
Wie tim schon sagte wer hat so viel geld und daniel,
das ist ja logisch total dumm nicht einmal pensionsfonds können sich das leisten die wurden ja schon in der letzten krise geplündert und sind chronisch unterfinanziert.
Das bedeutet wie auch bereits in den vorschlägen zu eurobonds angedacht dass banken die bonds für welche alle europäischen staaten haften zu negativzinsen ausgeben,
und die ezb dann geld druckt um diese zu kaufen und gleichzeitig eben diese banken sich mit drei bis fünf prozent eigenkapital eigentlich ganz normale dienstleister sind damit finanziert.
Dies wird damit.
Dies wird dann erneut damit begründet dass banken systemrelevant sind und unvorhersehbare kredit ausfälle von privatkunden aufgrund des corona virus hatten.
Ich will an dieser stelle noch mal anmerken dass man die deutsche bank gerade zum schnapperpreis von circa zwölf milliarden euro kaufen kann falls jemand interesse hat die deutsche bank setzt übrigens gerade ihre restrukturierungsmaßnahmen das heißt leute entlassen aus,
um so meine these sich jetzt vom staat durchfinanzieren zu lassen und gleichzeitig volle mitarbeiterzahl für die bewältigung der krise zu haben und vielleicht auch keine abfindung zahlen zu müssen.
Dadurch dass die ezb in diesem wirren system letztendlich doch einfach nur geld druckt.
Damit der häuslebauer seinen kredit bedienen kann kommt es unter umständen zu einer starken inflation oder im schlimmsten fall zu einem verfall des euro-raums aufgrund der hohen schuldenlast oder streitereien zwischen den mitgliedsländern
und einem anschließenden reset der natürlich deutlich schwerwiegender ist und ohne sozialistische staatsgewalt,
auch keine umverteilung schafft zumindest nicht von den top ein prozent zum rest der bevölkerung fazit.
Der turbo finanz kapitalismus läuft auf speed so weiter oder uns fliegt die eurozone auseinander oder wir versuchen mal ein paar stellschrauben im system zu drehen macht weiter so ich habe größten respekt vor eurer arbeit und wünsche euch nur das beste.
Soweit konrad ja können wir jetzt glaube ich erstmal hier nur so stehen lassen.
Ich werde zu dem zu dem aufkaufen noch was sagen in der markus land sendung,
in der ich ja zu gast da war auch walter kohl,
der sich spezifisch in der mittelständischen kfz- zulieferer szene,
bewegt hat also er hat ich glaube der war früher hat er selber einen betrieb als kfz zulieferer gehabt in der,
vor kurzem verkauft hat zwischen als unternehmensberater noch tätig und der setzt sich ein bisschen damit auseinander okay.
Wenn jetzt so ein dealer ein paar monate nicht.
Produziert und verkauft dann ist halt auch daimler sturmreif geschossen und dann.
Sagt eltern wird das ding halt aufgekauft und im zweifelsfall sagte,
aus china gleichzeitig hat er benannt dass halt diese kfz zulieferer natürlich insgesamt so ein bisschen mit ihrer produktion wann was bezahlt wird und so hinterher hängen.
Ja so dass er damit davon ausgeht dass es bei denen dann in drei monaten tatsächlich losgeht dass die kohle ausläuft weil die im moment noch bezahlt werden für arbeit diese geleistet haben der hat da auch ein sehr düsteres,
bild gezeichnet und spezifisch auch diesen aspekt benannt das jetzt wenn die wenn die sachen alle wert,
in ihrem wert sinken dass sich da halt ein paar käufer sehr freuen die gerade geld haben.
Würdest du auch diese these des desaster kapitalisten ja das immer wieder kräfte gibt die durchaus auch ein interesse daran haben dass systeme mal zusammenbrechen kontext brexit ist das oft genannt worden,
und dann sozusagen langfristig denken und sagen na ja mir doch egal wenn die nächsten zehn jahre katastrophal für viele leute sind ich habe ja genug geld und jetzt kann man schön billig kaufen und später stehe ich halt
besser da als vorher.
Das ist auf jeden fall der fall und ja es es ist eben eine tatsache wer selbst in der krise noch kapital hat ist im zweifelsfall kein facharbeiter am band.
Ja
Ja ich werde den lkw noch mehr zum wirtschaftlichen thema machen so wer interesse hat dann noch tiefer einzusteigen.
Wir gucken dann doch mal lieber was sich so politisch und netz politisch noch so tut.
Kleiner aufreger war das so ein strategiepapier des innenministeriums in den medien behandelt wurde das kam wohl so von der woche raus lag einigen redaktionen vor.
Aber eben wurde nicht veröffentlicht und nachdem einige medien darüber berichtet hatten kam dann frag den staat und hat dieses papier einfach mal,
angefordert und auch erhalten und es ist so ein siebzehn seitiges dokument.
Ja ich weiß nicht so genau was man davon halten soll ist im wesentlichen ist halt so nur für den dienstgebrauch et cetera und dort gab es halt eine gruppe von wissenschaftlerin so eine gruppe von rund zehn,
fachleuten darunter wissenschaftler des instituts der deutschen wirtschaft und vom rwe leibnitz institut für wirtschaftsforschung.
Und die haben halt dann unter anderem wenig überraschend für eine massive ausweitung von tests plädiert.
Das ist ja glaube ich auch in der aktuellen diskussion relativ klar man hat die vorbilder südkorea etcetera taiwan länder die eben,
schon auch systeme und vor allem viel erfahrung in place hatten und dementsprechend besser auf diese krise reagiert haben.
Und sehr viel hängt eben auch an dieser verfügbarkeit von tests das ist ja auch etwas was in deutschland angestrebt wird was für so ein bisschen aufregung gesorgt hat bei diesem strategiepapier war sein so diese formulierung man müsse doch in der
in der kommunikation nach außen sprich staat zu bevölkerung mehr auf schock wirkung setzen.
Als er dann immer so ein wort wo alle gleich durchdrehen.
Ja da freuen sich die die coronas verschwörungstheoretiker ne.
Ja ja genau jetzt wollen sie uns angst machen und so weiter so wie ich das lese und ich muss sagen ich habe jetzt nicht das siebzehn seiten dokument gelesen sondern nur die zusammenfassung.
Tim das ist okay aber da solltest du in so einer sendung hier nie zugeben ich lese das auch nicht wir haben immer ahnung okay.
Klar natürlich also ich meine ich atme das einfach ein wie so ein virus nehme ich das in mich auf,
und dann verbreitet sich das wissen in mir einfach exponentiell also,
es wurde halt gewarnt davor dass ebenso die öffentliche ordnung auseinanderfliegen könnte bis hin zu totaler anarchie
wurden verschiedene modellrechnungen auch aufgemacht so die klassischen abschätzung und simulationszentrum mit wie lange hält denn das gesundheitssystem welch bei welcher verbreitung was aus etcetera und
im wesentlichen ist diese strategiepapier also die darlegung von knapp drei szenarien.
Aber tim ich würde ganz kurz eine sache anmerken dass die öffentliche ordnung zusammenbricht und anarchie herrscht ist glaube ich dass die die prognose und die sorge jeglicher tätigkeit im innenministerium ja nur um das mal in kontext zu.
Du weißt so grundsätzlich immer.
Ja grundsätzlich ja klar das ist ja auch dass das deswegen weil mir der job ja auch auf dauer viel zu ermüdend ja so oh mein gott wenn das so.
Vielleicht glauben sie jetzt selber das erste mal dran.
Und es ist nicht nur ein talking point.
Nun aber sorry ist natürlich ein ernstes thema hier.
Genau und ja.
Diesmal wirklich.
Genau also unter anderem wird halt soll sozusagen in dieser öffentlichen kommunikation darauf hingewiesen werden dass eben nicht nur diese bisher diskutierten risikogruppen besonders in gefahr sei sondern das prinzip alle betrifft und das ist ja auch glaube ich in der berichterstattung der letzten tage
klar geworden international es gibt sehr wohl fälle von leuten die eben
auch jung verstorben sind an neunzehn es gibt viele die eben vielleicht nicht dran verstorben sind aber dann zumindest auch das risiko von langzeitschäden nach sich haben das geht eben auch
bist du kinder runter und auch wenn natürlich die verteilung bei den
älteren schwächeren und mit vorerkrankungen ausgestatteten menschen größer ist heißt es eben nicht dass man nicht betroffen sein kann das ist sozusagen das unter anderem wurde dann aber auch noch ohne weitere nennenswerte belege die nutzung von big data,
und location tracking gefordert ein thema was wir jetzt hier auch gleich noch aufnehmen werden ja.
Daten und locations erhält auch die polizei.
In insgesamt vier bundesländern habe ich das ja also bei bei netzpolitik org sind bisher vier bundesländer dokumentiert gibt aber glaube ich noch wahrscheinlich weitere fälle.
Genau also es ging in baden-württemberg los da gab's dann berichte die dann auch mittlerweile von
mehr als der hälfte der polizeipräsidien des landes baden-württemberg bestätigt worden dass halt gesundheitsämtern mindestens drei zumindest daten,
und das bedeutet quasi namen und wohnort über mit dem korona virus infizierte personen an die polizei gegeben hat.
Und da.
Das sozusagen mit der intention eines selbstschutz es der polizei weil kann ja sein dass man zu irgendeinem einsatzort gerufen wird und wenn die dann da alle verseucht sind dann muss ich dann halt auch die polizei zurückhalten,
hallo
ist natürlich eine interessante diskussion ähnliche pläne gibt es auch in bremen niedersachsen mecklenburg-vorpommern und ich denke mal die diskussion wird sich dann auch schnell auf andere länder ausbreiten wenn es nicht schon längst getan hat.
Die länder haben dann unterschiedlich reagiert insbesondere haben die datenschützer in diesen ländern unterschiedlich reagiert also in bremen wurde die ganze aktion von der datenschutzbeauftragten.
Zunächst einmal gestoppt mit der argumentation dass hierfür keine rechtsgrundlage gäbe und dass das sozusagen überhaupt das problem an dieser stelle dass hier einfach mal gesundheitsdaten geschert werden
haben wir uns ja hier nun auch lang und breit darüber da halten gerade auch in den letzten sendungen mit wem mit gesundheitsdaten denn umgegangen werden soll
und jetzt wurden die halt einfach mal so als liste per e-mail verschickt ist natürlich auch noch mal eine geile nummer ist.
Absoluter absoluter irrsinn und völlig völlig inakzeptabel und zwar aus mehreren gründen,
die sagen ja hier ja dass das dient dem schutz der polizisten ja unter der polizistinnen was nichts anderes bedeutet als dass die nicht ausreichend geschützt sind für den fall dass sie einer infizierten person begegnen,
ja also was die natürlich brauchen,
polizistinnen und polizisten genauso wie alle anderen menschen die gerade noch ausführlicher exponiert heit.
Zugrunde liegen ja weil sie.
Mit menschen zu tun haben müssen sei das eine mitarbeiterin oder ein mitarbeiter in einem supermarkt oder ein polizist oder jemand in einem krankenhaus die brauchen entsprechende,
schutzkleidung entsprechende schutzmaßnahmen das darf gar nicht so sein dass es für die eine dass sie die daten bräuchten wer eine corona infizierte person ist oder nicht,
denn.
Also vor allem ist es auch unsinnig weil insbesondere die person die infiziert sind denen ist das ja bekannt und die werden sich entsprechend schützen isolieren und sonst was ja das heißt,
genau die person der polizei mitzuteilen ist erstens unsinnig.
Und wird auch die polizei im zweifelsfall nicht davor schützen sich bei ihrer arbeit zu infizieren es gibt aber noch ein anderes problem hier ist mindestens ein fall bekannt.
Wo ist folgendermaßen lief handelt es sich um eine person die von,
die auf bestimmten todeslisten von rechtsradikalen steht.
Und die todeslisten von rechtsradikalen machen wir uns nichts vor sind größtenteils dadurch gefüttert dass alle polizei wie sie lust hat zugriff auf diese melderegister hat.
Aus diesen gründen können personen die sich dir also bedroht werden so auskunft schweren beantragen,
oder zum beispiel auch etwas machen wie sich an einem anderen wohnort melden.
Oder was weiß ich habe irgendwo einen zweitwohnsitz den sie nicht angeben wo sich die ganze zeit aufhalten und dann fliegen halt die steine beim bei irgendeiner leeren wohnungen in durch die durchs fenster so und
jetzt passiert folgendes gegenüber der dem gesundheitsamt gibt so eine person vielleicht dann auch tatsächlich an wo sie sich aufhält und sagt
bitte bitte bitte unter keinen umständen diese daten irgendjemandem weitergeben sondern die werden hier für diesen spezifischen zweck geheim gehalten dann kommt der gesundheitsminister oder was oder die polizei daher und sagt er gib mal her
und zacki zacki hast du eine geschützte adresse einer gefährdeten person in den händen der polizei.
Und dann hast du natürlich ein riesen problem.
Also das ist das ist sowas von eindeutig klar dass es dafür keine rechtsruck rechtsgrundlage geben kann und so ein,
unerhörtes vorgang der letztendlich nur zeigt dass die polizei nicht ordentlich geschützt wird und das ist der schließlich der punkt weshalb auch jede polizistin und jeder polizist sagen sollte wollte uns verarschen,
gib mal eine maske ja ihr gebt uns ja auch eine kugelsichere weste ja,
und das finde ich also hier völlig völlig verkloppt die sind diese idee und das skandal.
Zumal auch leute nach der dachte derzeitigen erkenntnislage leute die getestet worden sind.
Die sind nicht mehr das problem.
Die sind schon allein schon deshalb nicht mehr das problem weil halt die infektion zeit sich im wesentlichen so um fünf sechs sieben tage herum nach symptom beginnen bewegen so,
derzeit werden die leute eigentlich sowieso
frühestens getestet wenn sie symptome zeigen es sei denn du bist jetzt halt unmittelbar in so einer gemeldeten kontakt kette etcetera aber man kann davon ausgehen dass eben sehr viele leute davon betroffen sind die halt auch überhaupt gar keinen test bekommen haben von daher musst du sowieso bei die voll davon ausgehen dass jetzt irgendwie alle,
potenziell infiziert sein können deswegen gibt es dieses kontaktverbot
das ist der grund so wenn man das einfach mit meldeliste machen könnte wenn man ja schon zehn schritte weiter also das ist auf jeden fall ein zeichen von überreaktion und ja das muss,
ein ende finden das bringt uns dann zur generellen frage auch von grundrechten in diesen zeiten.
Man muss sich ja auch klar machen.
All diese ganzen maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen werden sind natürlich einschränkungen auch von grundrechten wir haben ein recht darauf und frei bewegen zu können etcetera und all diese ganzen auflagen die jetzt gemacht werden sind
einschränkungen dessen und da lohnt natürlich auch mal einen blick darauf was eigentlich das recht so vorsieht,
wenn man sich mal die grundrechte selber anschaut gibt's im grundgesetz gibt es so etwas wie ein ausnahmezustand gar nicht.
Und es gibt aber seit neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig im grundgesetz eine sogenannte notstands verfassung die bestimmte artikel noch mit hinzufügt eben für den fall dass eben ein notstand vorliegt,
und,
trotz alledem ist das etwas was erstens seitdem noch nie zur anwendung gekommen ist und soweit ich informiert bin auch bisher noch nicht zum einsatz gekommen,
an alle maßnahmen die wir jetzt haben basieren eigentlich eher auf der anwendung des infektionsschutz gesetzes was ja jetzt auch nochmal kurzfristig angepasst wurde,
um da mehr durchgriff auf bundesebene zu ermöglichen also all diese ganzen sachen die meldepflichtig keit berufsverbot et cetera was ich.
Was ich derzeit sozusagen abzeichnet und durchgesetzt wird dass das basiert soweit ich das ein schätzen kann,
im wesentlichen darauf grundgesetz hat im wesentlichen auch nichts konkretes zur.
Zum verhalten im solchen falle sondern es gibt halt generell in artikel elf den hinweis dass man eben.
Gesetze und das recht der freizügigkeit einschränken darf zur bekämpfung von solchen gefahr,
wie auch naturkatastrophen besonderen unglücksfällen etcetera aber im wesentlichen läuft es wohl alles,
so ab nichtsdestotrotz gibt es natürlich jetzt eine große breite und wichtige diskussion darüber was wir denn gegebenenfalls alles noch an einschränkungen zu erleiden haben beziehungsweise auf welcher gesetzmäßigkeit das brot.
Und dazu kommt natürlich auch die ganze frage,
überwachungs- debatte macht verschiebungen etcetera wir sehen das ja gerade in ungarn was ich dort abspielt hatte orban einfach mal das parlament ausgesetzt oder das parlament hat sich quasi selber ausgesetzt soweit sind die ja da auch schon und kann da jetzt einfach mal so durch.
Sehr einsichtig des parlament die haben anerkannt dass wir das problem sind und sich abgeschafft parlament wählt sich ab.
Also klassische ermächtigungsgesetz und dann ja geht's jetzt auch schon los jetzt werden erstmal so rechte von transsexuellen menschen eingeschränkt und so weiter weil das ist das was man braucht während einer solche.
Ganz wichtig jetzt haben sich auch nochmal zivilgesellschaftliche organisationen zu wort gemeldet da gibt's auch eine entsprechende,
pressemeldung oder meldungen generell auf c d e also nicht nur das c sondern verschiedene organisationen haben jetzt gerade die liste nicht zusammengeschrieben.
Es ist eine sehr lange liste.
Genau wir haben das hier thematisch auch schon mal gehabt weil du thomas auch daran beteiligt waren mal diese ganzen thesen zusammenzutragen wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Deswegen will ich das jetzt auch im einzelnen nicht wiedergeben aber so grundsätzlich geht es halt hier
im rechtmäßigkeit angemahnt wird dass bei
entsprechend eingeleiteten maßnahmen die jetzt grundrechte einschränken oder überhaupt rechte einschränken zumindest eine zeitliche begrenzung mit eingearbeitet wird daraufhin hat ja auch thomas jetzt nochmal berichtet als wir über die situation in österreich gesprochen haben
das klar wird wenn neue datensammlungen angelegt werden zum zwecke der pandemien bekämpfung dass es eben auch rechtlich entsprechend festgeschrieben ist dass diese eben nur auch genau dafür,
verwendet werden und die privatsphäre die dadurch gegebenenfalls berührt wird weitgehend erhalten werden kann das anonymität so sieht denn.
Behauptet wird nicht nur behauptet wird sondern,
auch nachgewiesen wird dass diese vorliegt dass also quasi datensammlung die anonym erhoben werden sollen dann eben auch entsprechend anonymisiert sind man das eben auch belegen kann,
keine gesetze erlassen werden die,
zur diskriminierung führen von minderheiten das hat man ja auch mal ganz schnell das dann irgendeine risikogruppe ausfindig gemacht wird oder behauptet wird die dann eben,
auch dazu führt dass dann nämlich eine öffentliche meinung dagegen stellen kann nach dem motto hier diese minderheit diese gruppe ist ja für uns alle gefährlich und deswegen müssen wir die jetzt mal bekämpfen um die mehrheit zu schützen.
Jenny virus.
Genau ne
wichtig auch der hinweis auf transparenz der maßnahmen also das wenn maßnahmen ergriffen werden diese nicht einfach nur ergriffen werden sondern dass man eben auch klar darlegt dass sie ergriffen werden warum sie ergriffen werden auf welche art und weise das
getan wird auf welcher gesetzlichen grundlage et cetera dass das dann eben auch verstanden werden kann,
und das vor allem bei diesen ganzen maßnahmen nie vergessen wird auch eine entsprechende rechenschafts pflicht und schutzmaßnahmen gegen den missbrauch mit einzubauen also dass man sagt
ja okay das ist jetzt das wir tun wollen aber wir wollen auch sicherstellen dass es eben nicht darüber hinaus schießt und das dann entsprechende strafen gibt oder auch klare rechtliche grenzen gibt die als solche dann auch
kann erkennbar sind damit es eben nicht,
in eine richtung abgeleitet die nicht ursprünglich gedacht war und dann ganz wichtiger punkt wie ich finde dass man immer wenn man eben sagt ok wir müssen jetzt hier mal in diesem bereich die rechte von bestimmten gruppen ein,
schränken ja was weiß ich kirchen war so als beispiel dass es dann.
Wichtig ist dann auch mittel bereitzustellen nicht nur für die umsetzung dieser maßnahme sondern das in diesen mitteln,
auch festgehalten ist dass man eine beteiligung relevanter interessengruppen auch mit vorsieht.
Die gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte gf hat ein umfangreiches zusammengestellt beobachtet
die situation und entwicklung laufend und aktualisiert auch diese sammlung
das ist ein schon relativ großes dokument lohnt sich auf jeden fall da mal so durchzuschauen weil halt da sehr schön beschrieben wird ok was
ist überhaupt bisher passiert auf welcher grundlage ist irgendetwas passiert was droht vielleicht noch et cetera pp die liste ist wirklich schon recht lange
und ja natürlich müssen wir da jetzt einen blick drauf werfen wie dieses polizeiball spiel schon mal zeigt und wir wahrscheinlich auch in zukunft noch,
weitere beispiele bekommen werden die hier diskussionswürdig sind.
Da wird sich vor allem auch zum beispiel was dran ändern also ich denke einer der spannendsten teile wird.
Wenn jetzt irgendwann mal also was sagst du zum beispiel eine person die diesen corona hinter sich hat so der kannst du eigentlich also der kann's eigentlich gar nichts mehr verbieten
weder die kann sowieso wenig abstand zu jeder person halten wie sie will die kann sich auch in beliebig großen gruppen mit anderen korona.
Geschützten personen versammeln was aber gleichzeitig heißt dass du da dass es dazu führt dass jemand der corona hatte in irgendeiner form sehr stark privilegiert wird komme ich jetzt auch nochmal zu wenn wir.
Über contact tracing reden das heißt diese grundrecht situation die ändert sich ja auch damit wie die mehrheitsverhältnisse in der gesellschaft sind was die exposition risiko und so weiter angeht.
Dann würde ich jetzt mal zu dem thema contact tracing kommen und eben der corona app wie gesagt es gab eine ganze reihe an feedback und es gab auch eine ganze reihe an einlassungen und artikeln zu dem thema.
Die sich primär auch versuchen,
mit dem epidemiologische sinn oder unsinn von contact tracing auseinanderzusetzen und da gibt es natürlich jetzt ein problem genauso wie bei jeder anderen debatte im internet hat sich ja sehr das kürzel,
etabliert für eloy und ich denke man braucht auch.
Wie und,
also ich bin kein epidemiologische und ich bin kein viro loge und natürlich dann auf deutsch immer nochmal komme aber ja und diesen das,
berücksichtigen sehr viele leute in dieser debatte nicht insbesondere auch teilweise landesbeauftragte für datenschutz die auf netzpolitik org gastbeitrag schreiben dürfen.
Also nochmal ganz klar damit wir uns hier einig sind was das der sinn einer solchen maßnahme ist der sinn einer solchen app wäre
flatten the im moment haben wir in deutschland immer noch unter einhunderttausend infizierte wird nicht mehr lange dauern sind's mehr aber im moment haben wir noch weniger.
Und haben trotzdem einen look down von millionen personen die gar keinen kontakt zu infizierten hatten oder haben werden,
diese app ist ein tool für nach dem look down und jetzt kommt das große,
enorme missverständnis bitte bitte zuhören bitte bitte merken eine solche app,
kann nicht der person helfen die andere notifiziert.
Also benachrichtigt und sie kann auch nicht der person helfen die eine benachrichtigung erhält.
Also weder ob ich diese benachrichtigung sende noch ob ich sie bekomme in beiden fällen kann mir diese app keine hilfe mehr sein das ist aber eine annahme der alle möglichen einlassungen zu dem thema auffliegen,
diese app hilft erst,
wenn die person die benachrichtigt wird danach ihre kontakte reduziert sie muss sich dafür auch nicht testen lassen oder sonst was alles quatsch ja diese,
app schützt immer den die dritte person in der reihe also den zweiten hopp.
Und deswegen würde eine solche app so die annahme wenn sie funktioniert eben auch risikogruppen ohne handy genauso schützen wie risikogruppen mit handy und so weiter,
also erst der die dritte person in der reihe wird geschützt man könnte also sagen wir würden eine solche app nutzen.
Um die kontakte unserer kontakte zu schützen.
Ob diese kontakte unserer kontakte ein smartphone haben kompatibles smartphone bluetooth sich nicht zum arzt gehen oder sonst was spielt alles keine rolle solange sich unsere benachrichtigten kontakte isolieren.
Und jetzt gibts dann den einmal die aber das funktioniert ja auch ohne so eine app oder ohne daten,
und das ist genau der punkt das tut es nämlich nicht denn im moment findet ein solcher prozess ebenfalls statt und zwar sehr mühsam durch die gesundheitsämtern also wenn du mit corona wenn du,
diagnostiziert wirst dass du korona hass mit anderen worten du hast symptome dann wird müll wenn mühselig wieder eine kontakte rückverfolgbarkeit den hinterher telefoniert.
Ein anderer das ist der prozess der hier beschleunigt werden soll und ja dieser prozess kann,
zum beispiel auch fehler beinhalten natürlich der würde sogar wahrscheinlich sehr viele fehler beinhalten,
denn es scheint ja tatsächlich so zu sein dass selbst bei einem sogenannten risiko kontakt die wahrscheinlichkeit dass du dich ansteckst relativ gering ist irgendwo bei fünf prozent,
vielleicht zehn oder fünfzehn und es gibt natürlich auch dass das andere beispiel was leute hier anführen.
Den fall du wirst von einer du wirst von der,
hustende joggerinnen bei windstärke fünf infiziert ja denn dann taucht das in deiner app gar nicht auf,
richtig aber spätestens wenn du dein infiziert bist kannst du wieder deine kontakte wirten und die wiederum sich von ihren anderen kontakten fernhalten,
das ist die idee also eine selected ein selektiver lok down der eben auch wiederkehrend sein könnte.
Und das ist überhaupt die idee einer solchen app wer.
Ein argument gegen die app vorbringt was mit dieser argumentation nichts zu tun hat muss sich mit seinem argument noch einmal auseinandersetzen.
Es gab dann noch in den kommentaren den hinweis diese app wäre ja eine lebenslange verpflichtung,
auch das ist nicht der fall der begriff der hier berücksichtigt werden müsste ist,
herden immunität wir tragen ja auch keine masern mumps röteln keuchhusten oder poppen app mit uns rum weil diese krankheiten sich nicht mehr exponentiell verbreiten weil der größere teil der gesellschaft dagegen immun ist.
Und genau bis zu diesem punkt wahrscheinlich sogar noch viel früher müsste eine solche app überhaupt angewendet werden,
der.
Christian droste zitiert im corona update nummer siebenundzwanzig erklärt er eine science studie die sehr genau,
die möglichkeiten einer solchen app mal ausgerechnet hat mit und,
quasi den effekt sieht und natürlich redet man immer von einer kombination von maßnahmen ja.
Also es ist ein großes missverständnis dass diese app jene schützen solle oder könne die sie nutzen und.
Daraus ergeben sich eben eine ganze reihe an leider unsinnigen interpretationen der lage.
Kommen wir zu der allgemeinen lager es gibt in der gesellschaft,
eine sehr hohe akzeptanz für solche maßnahmen.
Wir standen vor zwei drei,
vor zwei wochen noch bei der frage dass hier standortdaten von mobilfunknetzen und handys genutzt werden wir haben im moment die berichte darüber dass hier so einen überwachungs- friese wie palentin sich in diese debatte einmischen,
und wir haben's jetzt geschafft innerhalb kürzester zeit.
Die debatte durch warnung und durch aufzeigen von privatsphäre erhaltenen technologien in eine richtige richtung zu zeigen ja wir haben.
Diskussion um standortdaten hat sich erledigt und.
Wir können uns jetzt überlegen ob wir in einer solchen situation wo viele leute so etwas wollen wo viele begehrlichkeiten natürlich da sind das schlimmste.
Verhindern können es gab ja auch den ein oder anderen kommentar oh mein gott ne die leute vom c machen jetzt in tracking und so weiter das gegenteil ist der fall wir haben die letzten,
zwei drei jahrzehnte eine menge an krypto und privacy technologien gebaut,
und diese technologien müssen jetzt da einfließen ja wir haben enorme gestaltungsbild oder für privacy bei design und.
In diesem bereich und es ist wichtig diese jetzt dort einzubringen ja wir haben ja genau diese technologien weil wir uns gegen massenüberwachung seit jahrzehnten wehren und immer wieder neue technologien bauen,
die haben wir ja und die müssen jetzt da rein damit hier keine massenüberwachung entsteht ja.
Es wird selbstverständlich kein c geben.
Das ist klar und auch ich will lieber keine solche app ich will aber auch lieber keine korona krise haben aber wenn wir in einer situation sind dann doch wohl bitte unter den höchsten privacy anforderungen die,
möglich sind.
Generelles argument das auch immer wieder angebracht wurde sind genauigkeit oder ungenauigkeiten einer solchen
messung also du bist einer person über stunden sehr nahe zwischen euch befindet sich aber eine glasscheibe,
du wirst na die hustende joggerin bei windstärke fünf das heißt diese app wird dich manchmal nicht alarmieren.
Und es wird sogar so sein dass sie dich häufig wenn sie dich alarmiert trotzdem keine infektion.
Stattgefunden hat aber wir müssen ja immer wieder daran denken dass wir hier exponentielle effekte verhindern wollen das heißt es ist auch tolerable dass die app dich eventuell mal nicht alarmiert weil spätestens du alarmiert ja dann wieder.
Es geht also am ende um einen allgemein und keinen individuellen effekt und du schützt immer,
am ende eine dritte person die du vielleicht gar nicht kennst oder von der du gar nicht weißt dass du sie schützt und sie wird eventuell nie erfahren dass sie geschützt wurde.
Die hört nur was weiß ich der micha der hat eine der hat eine notification bekommen der hat sich isoliert jetzt hat der symptome ich habe den micha letzte woche nicht getroffen keine ahnung wer mit der app zu tun hat oder nicht.
Außerdem gibt es natürlich diese ganze kritik ist unter der annahme dass die app nicht.
Eine gestützte erfassung machen würde also es besteht ja durchaus auch die möglichkeit
dass du irgendwo sitzt ja mit einer person das kriterium für kontakt wird erreicht und die app sagt nur mal ganz kurz hör mal habe ich das gerade mit richtig mitbekommen dass ihr das hier gerade in kontakt stattfindet und du kannst sagen nee komm der nicht oder ja hast du richtig.
Mitbekommen.
Und ein schutz für den zweiten hopp nach dir würde immer noch bleiben also ja nichts bietet hundertprozentigen schutz genauso wie eine schutzmasken genauso wie wie eine isolierung nicht aber wir reden immer hier von maskeneffekt.
Dann gibt es ein sehr wichtigen zweig den wir in der technischen debatte nicht so berücksichtigt haben und zwar ist das die,
die gesellschaftliche wirkung zum beispiel also wurden viele kommentare zugeschrieben wir haben die kommentare die ich da relevant fand einfach in den shownotes verlinkt,
erstens wir werden in eine zeit kommen in der.
Infiziert gewesen zu sein ein enormes privileg ist ja das wird auf dem arbeitsmarkt zu einem enormen vorteilhafte marker werden.
Und das bedeutet wiederum das nicht infiziert gewesen zu sein oder eben nicht immun zu sein zu einem enormen nachteil.
Führt da hat er mir einen kommentar dazu gehabt der sehr klar sagt naja das horrorszenario für so einen club oder so 'ne kneipe oder sowas ist ja
dass es einen erneuten shutdown gibt oder dass dieser spezifische laden nochmal zu machen muss das heißt wenn du nur eine korona.
Personen bei dir im in der bude hast bringst du deine gäste in gefahr und erhöht erhöhst das risiko dass ein neuer shutdown kommt dass du zugemacht ist das oder vielleicht du zugemacht wird oder schlechte presse hast das heißt jeder betrieb wird motiviert sein alle angestellten und kunden.
Darauf zu kontrollieren dass sie den status nicht infiziert oder am besten immun,
vorweisen können und genauso könnten die kunden sagen haben wir da gehe ich nicht hin weil die das nicht kontrollieren das ist ein problem das ist aber ein problem was wir mit und ohne eine solche app haben werden und.
Klar das habe ich aber auch in der letzten sendung gesagt wir müssen.
Wenn man eine solche app hat dafür sorgen dass gesellschaftliche konsequenzen daraus letztendlich.
Auf basis des antidiskriminierung grundsatzes letztendlich verboten werden müssen auch wenn gerade dieser teil mit den.
Corona checks in der gastronomie oder so natürlich aus sicht aller beteiligten eigentlich positiv wären das wäre aber das problem werden wir haben unabhängig davon ob sie eine app gibt oder nicht dann kam.
Das klassische airbag oder rad helm argument wo gesagt wird die leute seid die leute in airbag haben fahren sie schneller weil sie glauben sie sie crashen weich oder so,
sorry das argument trifft hier nicht zu weil es immer nur um den um die dritte person geht also um den zweiten hop dessen reine nächstenliebe app.
Und das trifft eben leider nicht zu,
und dann gibt es noch diesen aspekt ja rache oder dankbarkeit also wer hat mich infiziert bin ich jetzt recht ich mich an der person habe ich der person dankbar weil ich bei dem ich auch in die,
privilegierte klasse gehoben hat oder die chance gegeben hat die privilegierte klasse zu erreichen wir wissen wenn du den klassen aufstieg probst so dass es immer auch mit einem gewissen,
risiko verbunden dass du dabei drauf gehst ne.
Aber dieses problem haben wir jetzt auch schon und de facto eigentlich umso mehr denn momentan wird diese benachrichtigungs arbeit vom gesundheitsamt erledigt die ist zu langsam das heißt du hast schon wieder andere angesteckt und.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher dass schon alle ungefähr wissen weshalb sie den anruf vom gesundheitsamt bekommen haben oder auch wo sie sich angesteckt haben.
So dann gab es eine ganze menge meldungen die sich zusammenfassen lassen mit aber aber bluetooth.
Böse.
Ja also.
Das ist natürlich erstmal ein valides argument das durch das einschalten von bluetooth grundsätzlich eine angriffsfläche auf dem gerät,
entsteht die vielleicht vorher nicht da war es gibt außerdem eine reihe an theoretischen und praktischen angriffen über bluetooth die.
Kürzlich und auch vor längerer zeit demonstriert wurden das ist richtig.
Jetzt gibt es aber.
Also daraus ist erstmal zu schließen und der wurde auch gezeigt hier bestimmte schwachstellen in bluetooth sind in ich glaube in android acht und neun immer noch ungefiltert
und das wird jetzt als argument angeführt dass man eben eine solche bluetooth low energy dutzende korona contact racing app nicht bauen könnte
oder dürfte weil diese uralt scheiß android immer noch irgendwelche weinmobil ladies haben ich würde dieses argument hinzufügen es wäre echt super wenn im android ökosystem mal diese dann doch etwas älteren variabilität entfernt würden denn,
wir kennen jetzt an den punkt dass man sagen könnte android tüten.
Weil die leute jetzt irgendwie kein bluetooth anmachen das ist also da muss man schon überlegen wie rum hier das argument geführt wird des weiteren muss man.
Schon klar im auge behalten es gibt schwachstellen die.
Praktischer natur sind und es gibt schwachstellen die theoretische natur sind das heißt es gibt.
Wie sich die schwachstelle in der welt da draußen tatsächlich manifestiert in form von wie leute geordnet werden oder nicht.
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche paar schuhe und ich,
muss leider sagen dass mir keine person bekannt ist das kann sich auch ändern ja aber bisher ist mir keine person bekannt und auch keinen fall bekannt wo unter,
bedingungen der realen welt irgendjemand über bluetooth geahnt worden wäre,
das kann damit zu tun haben dass die meisten leute die ich kenne aktuelle betriebssysteme ohne schwachstellen benutzen aber.
Man muss bei einer schwachstellen begutachtung eben auch realistisch bleiben so das.
Heißt nicht dass ich dieses risiko vollständig ignoriere selbstverständlich sind ungeputzte schwachstellen auf irgendwelchen android-telefon ein problem die waren aber auch vor und nach koronaren problem.
Und müssen unabhängig davon entfernt werden.
Dann gab es eine reihe an technischen einlassungen die ich jetzt hier an der stelle etwas schneller bespreche und zwar also erstmal gab's dann auch einige.
Kluge hinweise dazu dass in der darstellung in der letzten sendung aber auch in meinem blogpost bestimmte.
Bestimmte angriffs klassen nicht berücksichtigt wurden klar wir machen hier einen podcast für
viele viele zehntausend hörerinnen und hörer und werden hier nicht ein vollständiges
wissenschaftliches paper vorstellen ich komme gleich zu den projekten und propose die das getan haben das heißt selbstverständlich habe ich sowohl in diesem podcast als auch auf meinem blog post als auch bei markus lanz von,
grundsätzlichen anforderungen und grundsätzlichen möglichkeiten gesprochen um zu illustrieren dass eben dieses ziel einer tracing app,
erreicht werden kann mit minimalem bis gar keinem privatsphäre verletzungen.
Und das ist ja das entscheidende wenn wir davon ausgehen müssen dass eine solche app kommt.
Gleichzeitig habe ich natürlich nicht für jede für jeden offensichtlich oder auch nischen angriff bei dieser allgemeinen high level,
hoffentlich massen kompatiblen darstellung an jedes angriffsszenario gedacht ok kommen wir zu den.
Technischen details es wird bei bei beacons auch eine make a dresse mit gesendet es wird würde schwierig schwierig die zuverlässig auszuholen.
Nein bei den meisten geräten gibt es mac and adresse station.
Aber ja das ist ein eine technisch zu lösende herausforderung.
Dann das argument das smartphones ja auch anderweitig korreliert ware infos aussenden.
Zum beispiel wifi pro quests.
Und bluetooth und diese würden auch heute schon zum tracking und wiedererkennen von kundinnen genutzt.
Ja stimmt das ist aber eben auch heute schon so ja und es ist ein.
Im prinzip ein gegenteiliges argument das eben durch verwendung einer solchen technologie nicht,
besonders das problem erhöhen würde was du heute schon hast denn du bist trackbar über deine wifi pro request insofern,
muss sich niemand mehr die mühe machen dich über irgendwelche bluetooth energy beacons zu tracken.
Kurz zur erläuterung von wifi request das zeigt im prinzip dein handy fragt in regelmäßigen abständen nach wlands die es kennt und da die kombination an wlands die du kennst im prinzip ein,
individuelles merkmal von dir beziehungsweise deinem gerät ist.
Ermöglicht dass das tracking von personen und hier wird der wird das argument gebracht dass damit ja wiederum auch dein bluetooth flow energy bieten korreliert werden könnte.
Ja ist ein ist ein punkt könnte passieren ist ein freds szenario skaliert nicht so sehr.
Ist der grund warum du deinen bieten andauernd änderst und ist aber ein problem.
Dann wichtiges argument replay angriffe ja also,
das beispiel ich würde irgendwo rum gehen alle codes die ich habe irgendwie sammeln und die,
an anderen stellen andauernd erneut senden sodass wenn sich eine dieser personen als infiziert meldet noch viel mehr menschen eine notification bekommen als mit der person tatsächlich.
Kontakt hatten wird aber gesagt ja im prinzip also.
Die lösung wird dazu auch direkt mitgeliefert in kommentar in den biegen müsste auch dann doch die zeit miteinfließen sodass du aufzeichnet ich habe diesen bieten um diese uhrzeit gehört.
Und das könnte bei der veröffentlichung dann auch wieder eine rolle spielen diese zeit anzugeben sodass.
Du
Quasi dann erkennen kannst ich habe diesen bieten gehört und ich habe ihn aber auch zur richtigen zeit gehört andere ansätze sind dass der die zeit rein geschlüsselt wird in den bieten.
Das ist bei einem der am weitesten verbreiteten ansätze der fall der hat allerdings.
Schöne eigenschaft dass jetzt natürlich auch,
zurück gerechnet werden kann aus jedem biegen wem der gehört also da kommt wieder andere probleme hinzu ich will hier nicht unbedingt die debatten aufmachen die technischen debatten die wir hinter den kulissen die ganze zeit führen.
Aber ja also dieses problem ist da dieses problem,
lösbar und es ist richtig dass es unter umständen das die lösung dieses problems wieder neue aufmacht total korrekt da eben auch der hinweis warum ich eine grobe schilderung des konzeptes vorgenommen habe und nicht.
Und zumindest bei mir nicht ein vollständiges paper über alle privacy erschienen ist andere erwähne ich gleich nochmal.
Dann gab es den punkt dass.
Von slutty war der hin von kommentar in den letzten sendungen durch viele gute kommentare aufgefallen übrigens und sagt.
So er war nämlich jetzt mal jemand der selber damit arbeitet und sagt hier ich habe.
Arbeite selber mit ios und die erlauben apps nur diese zu senden während sie im vordergrund aktiv sind und auf empfang seite kann man nur auf beacons lauschen aber nicht.
Offen also du kannst sagen ich will bescheid kriegen wenn bestimmte bieten gesendet werden aber ich kann nicht sagen ich will alle bekommen.
Apple nagelt alles zu und es ist sehr sinnvoll diese form von restriktionen auf einer app zu haben weil biegen es eben eigentlich für die lokalisierung gedacht sind also.
Guter punkt dass apple das macht lösung wäre,
wurde auch glaube ich in den kommentaren nachgeliefert du könntest quasi so ein wake-up bieten setzen ja das also das handy muss wenn es ein notifiziert,
notifiziert erstmal ein wake-up bieten senden damit die ganzen apple geräte aufwachen und dann den wirklichen bieten.
Jetzt gibt es aber die.
Ja inzwischen vorgestellte und mit der meisten aufmerksamkeit gesehene lösung p t komme ich gleich noch mal drauf wo deren initiator sagt er hätte für dieses problem,
eine lösung mit apple vereinbart und das war ohnehin denke ich bei einem solchen mammut ding.
Wahrscheinlich notwendig oder zielführend eventuelle restriktionen.
Die ist jetzt bei apple oder google geben könnte zu lockern für diese spezifische app kommt aber das nächste problem.
Das könnte bedeuten dass die app bestimmte dinge tut die man nicht open source n kann damit andere sie nicht tun,
könnte aber auch einfach nur bedeuten dass apple bestimmte nutzung von private dieser spezifischen einen app zulässt und bei allen anderen nicht.
Alles bisschen zu tief im detail für jetzt die breite bürgerschaft aber ich wollte darauf wenigstens noch kurz eingehen.
Letzter punkt in dem augenblick in dem ein code verifiziert wird zum beispiel von einer ärztin.
Sind die daten nicht mehr anonym denn die gehören ja in dem fall gehören ja dann codes zu einer infizierten person jain denn.
Könntest beispielsweise von der ärztin nicht deine codes signieren lassen sondern nur,
einen hash über alle deine codes sodass die ärztin nicht wirklich deine codes gesehen hat andere ansätze sehen sogenannte tanz vor also du hast eine du bekommst eine transaktionsnummer,
mit der du jetzt deine codes freisetzen kannst und diese transaktionsnummer hast du von einer ärztin bekommen so dass hier eben doppelseitige pseudonymen gewahrt werden kann.
Das sind alles sehr wichtige hinweise und es sind aber auch alles welche für dieses einerseits eine lösung gibt die andererseits auch wieder andere probleme hat.
Fakt ist es ist an keiner stelle notwendig personen mit codes zu lenken und deswegen müssen wir auch darauf achten dass darauf verzichtet wird und nicht alle propose die da draußen so,
kursieren tun das tatsächlich und deswegen arbeiten auch gerade wirklich inzwischen.
So so ungefähr alle datenschutz in privacy expertin die irgendwie.
Von mir also oder viele der leute mit hohem rang und namen und lorbeeren und.
Die renommierten.
Renomiert renommierte computer spezialisten sehr renommierte,
jutta spezialisten arbeiten an diesen dingen und führen natürlich hinter der hinter den kulissen in den communitys in den gizmo und in ihren snacks und wo die alle diese debatten führen.
Eine ganze reihe an auseinandersetzungen die aber eben zielführend sind und nicht immer sagen das geht aber gar nicht weil und.
Abschließend würde ich sagen selbstverständlich ist das hier das sollte man sich auch vor augen führen das ist ein.
Projekt von riesigen ausmaß das ist ein projekt.
Mit unglaublich vielen fallstricken aber mein kernargument ist wir haben technologien.
Und wir haben expertinnen.
Die sich mit all diesen problemen schon auseinandergesetzt haben und wir haben hier die gelegenheit dass mit privacy bei design zu lösen und auch wenn ich das selber im zweifelsfall auch,
besser fände ohne eine solche app klarzukommen würde ich es bevorzugen dass wenn ich so eine app haben muss.
Oder sollte oder wenn ich mit dieser app ein versprechen bekomme ein.
Im dritten einen zweiten hopp und eine dritte person in irgendeiner form zu schützen und für mich selber am ende auf meinem gewissen eine geringere last zu haben andere angesteckt zu haben.
Die leute die ich selber angesteckt habe sind ein problem die leute die die dann wiederum anstecken die habe ich aber auch ein gewissen und wenn ich das.
Auch noch weiter minimieren könnte ist das schon eine sehr feine angelegenheit und das ohne privatsphäre risiken zu erreichen wäre doch im zweifelsfall eine sehr.
Erstrebenswerte angelegenheit und wir befinden uns es kann möchte ich nochmal abschließend betonen in einer welt in der der größere teil der gesellschaft dazu bereit ist das auch.
Problemlos.
Unter inanspruchnahme der des entschuldigung in der der größere teil der gesellschaft bereit ist das auch ohne privatsphäre zu tun ja,
und das ist der der die auseinandersetzung die wir hier führen.
Bei lanz habe ich gesagt zu zeiten des friedens wenn wir solche sachen selbstverständlich nicht befürworten oder unterstützen.
Aber wir befinden uns hier auf wirklich in einer situation wo wir im prinzip einmal sagen können wollen wir unser gesamtes.
Wissen der letzten jahrzehnte die wir in privacy technologien aufgebaut haben in so einer lösung sehen wenn wir schon nicht verhindern wollen können dass sie kommt und da denke ich kann man eine,
informierte entscheidung treffen eine sache die ich auch bei lands betont habe ich bin kein.
Epidemiologische und ich kann nicht sagen ob das tatsächlich etwas bringt oder nicht.
Das,
ist nicht das argument was ich führe dieses argument führen andere an und die haben's immerhin damit geschafft in science veröffentlicht zu werden das kann was heißen es kann auch nichts heißen aber
die beurteilung der möglichkeit der wirkung obliegt anderen und.
Natürlich tim hat es ja gerade auch schon gesagt jede maßnahme muss zweckgebunden sein.
Und muss auch ihre effizienz unter beweis stellen und jetzt gibt es bei gerade zum beispiel einen artikel der zirkuliert das singapur.
Die mit einer tracing app gearbeitet haben die übrigens nicht anonym war wohl sondern eine telefonnummer gebunden war.
Den look down dann doch wieder hochziehen wird weil sie sagen dass das projekt ist im prinzip gescheitert wir wissen.
Weil ich glaube das zitat war bei fünfzig prozent der neuinfektionen nicht wo sie herkommen mit anderen worten wir wir können hier nicht zurück tresen wie die sich infiziert haben.
Kann ich nur nochmal darauf hinweisen dass das ziel dieser app wäre eben bei einer neuen infektion die weiterverbreitung einzudämmen.
Insofern auch dieses zitat leider ein bisschen an der app vorbeigeschossen trotzdem.
Und natürlich ist das,
epidemiologische klar sagen dass sollten wir tun das ist diesen massiven aufwand wert massive geld was da investiert werden muss und den die
eine noch nie dagewesene so schnelle verbreitung einer solchen app wert dass wir es versuchen weil wir dadurch als gesellschaft einen immensen vorteil hätten nämlich am ende den dass wir aktuell in einer situation sind das
viele millionen menschen sich im look down befinden vollkommen unnötigerweise.
Und eine maßnahme die das für viele andere erleichtern könnte und die möglichkeit gibt infektionskrankheiten zu unterbrechen.
Wahrscheinlich eine sehr gute möglichkeit sein könnte so die epidemiologische das sagen einerseits die exponentielle ausbreitung im griff zu haben,
andererseits irgendwann wieder mit einem normalen leben anzufangen.
Aber dass das geht und ob das geht müssen andere beurteilen wir können nur den bescheidenen teil.
Beitragen dass dann eben privatsphäre schützend oder unter vollständiger privatsphäre zu tun.
Und nicht mehr und nicht weniger aber das wäre wahrscheinlich würde ich jetzt bescheiden sagen relativ wichtiger beitrag.
Das wäre so denke der teil der dazu zu sagen ist es wurde dann noch.
Gezeigt oder angemerkt dass jetzt bekannt wird das parlament hier versucht sich in diese sache einzubringen und da ihre hilfe anbieten palentin ist ein von peter thiel,
gelauncht des unternehmen das im prinzip im data überwachungsstaat herze und so weiter macht.
Irgendwie größter kunde sind irgendwelche us-geheimdienste für die die irgendwie überwachungstechnologien liefern also wirklich so sauron hat seine hilfe angeboten,
und ein kostengünstigen ring,
vorgeschlagen und aber genau das ist der punkt warum sich jetzt eben die ganzen privatsphäre expertinnen und experten in diesem bereich einbringen um zu zeigen es geht anders.
Und da in die richtung zu pushen weil letztendlich hätte würde das im zweifelsfall auch mit balanciert durchziehen und hinkriegen wäre meine fürchterliche befürchtung.
Ähm.
Kurzer überblick zu projekten und propose in diesem bereich was mir im prinzip am meisten sorge macht ist dass sich hier noch nicht alle kapazitäten.
In diesem bereich gebündelt haben.
Sondern es immer noch eine reihe an projekten gibt die sich hier mit unterschieden.
In diese richtung bewegen die von mir besprochenen beispiele aus dem wir wirsing virus hacker von haben sich gemerkt,
ito also ein projekt die quasi jetzt zusammenarbeiten und sagen wir wir bündeln unsere kräfte.
Es gibt außerdem das bisher größte und stärkste konglomerat was eben auch mit einiger mit einigen pomp vorgestellt wurde und an dem auch das.
Mitspielt was wiederum darauf hindeutet dass es unter im zweifelsfall dass diejenige ist was die größte aussicht auf erfolg hat.
Da habe ich im detail auch noch einige punkte einzuwenden weil.
Dieses propose macht vieles richtig hat aber den.
Für mich noch etwas problematischen nachteil dass man nicht seine eigenen codes veröffentlicht sondern die die man empfangen hat was.
Diese gesamten privacy annahmen etwas.
Aufweicht und letztendlich das wissen über kontakte pseudonymisierung auf einem zentralen server sammelt.
Das ist problematisch und da muss man sich mit auseinandersetzen es gibt ein weiteres problem das ist wenn man überhaupt einen solchen zentralen server hat hat man das problem eines jeden servers nämlich dass.
Im prinzip ja die ip-adressen der mittendrin sammeln kann und damit persönlich personengebunden informationen sammeln könnte.
Um spezifisch dieses problem und noch einige andere anzugehen gibt's einen sehr guten,
vorschlag vorschlags dokument von jonas logan den privacy preseason contact tracer das ist auf jeden fall.
Der next level shit mit mixed messages und so um da noch mal eine reihe probleme zu lösen.
Es gibt dann noch das die central privacy surving city tracking.
Racing.
Racing meine güte also es ist wirklich ein ein zungenbrecher.
Abkürzungen hölle ist das wieder die auf uns.
Eine abkürzung fälle ja aber was ich muss auch ehrlich sagen diese abkürzung hölle zeigt so ein bisschen dass wir uns auf dem richtigen weg befinden weil
das zeigt dass hier nicht die marketing maschinerie an erster front ist sondern halt
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler die sagen die privacy so heißt das nunmal,
drei p t fertig ja also hier werden hier werden die dinger nicht nach schönheit benannt sondern nach funktionalität und das da,
im prinzip ein gutes zeichen.
Und das was wir jetzt sorge macht so ein bisschen ist wie kriegen wir jetzt am ende wird nur eine implement station das rennen machen.
Wie kriegen wir jetzt möglichst viel von diesem wissen vereint und auf viele kräfte auf eine sache gebündelt.
Das ist denke ich die das problem und was jetzt glaube ich notwendig ist ist ein bisschen.
Corona rosinen zu picken und dafür zu sorgen.
Dass das eine alle vorteile in einer app gesammelt werden in einem propose.
Und dieses dann eben umzusetzen sofern die epidemiologische grundlage dafür gegeben ist dass wir ein solches mammut ding überhaupt machen.
Dann kommt von neu noch also auf ihr business der die max schrems gegründet hat eine der dsgvo berücksichtigt betrachtung von solchen apps die kommt.
Eben in dem fall nur von expertinnen formuliert zu einem zu einem ähnlichen anforderungen es muster.
Wie ich es entworfen habe oder dargestellt habe in der letzten sendung zusammengefasst haben in der letzten sendung hab ich ja nicht selber entworfen sondern es sind im prinzip.
Generelle anforderungen aber das sehr schön für sowohl.
Bürgerrechtlerinnen und bürgerrechtler als auch juristinnen und juristinnen anderer kuller mals auch den juristischen hintergrund.
Dieser ganzen idee.
Zu beachten und zu sehen was man da eigentlich alles für probleme lösen muss und ja das sind noch sehr viel mehr als ich in der letzten sendung.
Entworfen habe ja bleibt sauber.
Ja es wird sehr interessant sein zu sehen wie sich insbesondere diese konkurrenzsituation da entwickelt jetzt gar nicht mal nur so zwischen den einzelnen projekten die in deutschland im gespräch sind sondern man kann natürlich davon ausgehen dass jetzt in
allen möglichen staaten ähnliche projekte diskutiert und gestartet werden und dann mit natürlich in gewissen nationalen
präferenz allein schon aufgrund der einfachen kommunikation darüber
vorangetrieben werden in irgendeiner richtung mit unterschiedlichen sensitivitäten für diese privatsphäre diskussion da sind wir glaube ich in deutschland einfach generell gut aufgestellt für ungarn mache ich mir da jetzt nicht so viel hoffnung zum beispiel ja.
Genau da würde ich noch einen kurzen ein kurzes einen kurzen punkt anbringen.
Dieses ist ein vorschlag der sich.
Am meisten von denen die ich bisher gesehen habe um dieses internationalität ding kümmert die haben nämlich dafür gesorgt im prinzip so 'ne art also die gehen im prinzip davon aus es gibt einen,
ein server zur notification in jedem land und wenn du dich jetzt über deine ländergrenze hinaus bewegst,
sendest du in deinem bieten quasi so eine länder mit die dann auf dem,
server wieder dazu führen würde dass der sagt okay diesen da muss ich jetzt im anderen land bescheid sagen,
jetzt kommt natürlich das problem wenn du eine länder mit sendest dann hast du in deinem biegen unter umständen das problem dass er relativ einfach zu erkennen ist da war nämlich der einzige holländer der an dem tag da saß und,
dann geht es natürlich wiederum diese länder zu verstecken wenn du das tust dass sie dann am ende nur der server erkennen kann dann gibst du wieder eine identifikations-
Möglichkeit und eine abschwächung der anonymität gegenüber diesem server und das sind so die debatten die eben gerade in den fachkreisen geführt werden.
Aber von dem propos sitzt die ich jetzt sehe scheint mir das.
Das jenige zu sein dass insbesondere zum beispiel auch schonmal roaming berücksichtigt und.
Natürlich dann trotzdem würde es eben in dem beispiel ungarn vollkommen.
Ausreichend wenn dann was weiß ich die ungarische app sagt ach übrigens.
Bei uns bitte noch mal kurz personalausweis nummer angeben ja also mit winzigen details,
kannst du so eine app sofort wieder zerschießen und dann stellt sich wiederum die frage ob da nicht eventuell ungarinnen und ungarn sagen können weißt du was ich nehme.
Die die deutsche app oder die schwedische also da sind noch eine ganze reihe an an themen am start.
Die wir hier jetzt in der breite gar nicht berücksichtigen.
Ja auf jeden fall ich meine in gewisser hinsicht das ist natürlich hier auch survival auf zu fit ist so also ich meine das system was am besten funktionieren wird dann hat sozusagen auch eine chance sich am markt durchzusetzen weil
ja auch einen gewissen erfolg zeigen können wird ja man wird ja später dann auch schon auch sagen können okay so und so viele leute wurden hier gewarnt und der dritte hopp wurde geschützt etcetera,
das wird sich ja irgendwann dann auch alles herauslesen lassen aus den aktivitäten verstehe bei diesem ansatz von diesem pepp
tu das ding mit der anerkennung ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht weil in dem moment wo man halt sagt,
wenn ich als infiziert nachgewiesen wurde und ich melde das sozusagen dann wäre es ja auch überhaupt gar kein problem wenn meine meine kontakte sozusagen,
auch in andere länder geschickt werden wer auch immer mit mir kontakt hatte wird es dann halt erfahren vollkommen egal aus welchem land da,
kommt so wie es jetzt auch egal ist aus welchem bundesland das ist oder welcher stadt oder so ist
es geht einfach um kontakt und habe ich den gesehen oder nicht und ob das jetzt irgendwie an der grenze stattgefunden hat oder bei der beim pendeln über die grenze gibt's natürlich auch trackerfahrer etcetera p
ist egal ja dann dann dann kann man einfach diese information auch global bereitstellen und man ändert nichts daran.
Ja kann ich aber gar nicht erklären ganz kurz warum das so ist weil bei peppi veröffentlichst du nicht deine codes sondern die die du empfangen hast.
Ja ja klar aber das ist.
Ja aber das das ist der punkt der der server notiz fight dann deine kontakte und deswegen brauchen die diese länder kennung.
Aber lass uns jetzt nicht in alle details absteigen ich glaube es war kompliziert genug.
Es ist so dass bei peggy eben ein entscheidendes ding anders gemacht wird und die deswegen andere vorkehrungen haben.
Belassen wir es bitte dabei aber dass sie eine länder erkennung haben und brauchen ist der fall.
Grundsätzlich finde ich's ja gut wenn sozusagen die diskussion auch schon frühzeitig auf wir brauchen da eigentlich einen standard hingeführt wird auch wenn natürlich,
einigkeit insbesondere internationale einigkeit jetzt noch sehr viel schwerer kurzfristig zu erzielen ist von daher werden wir ohnehin nationaler,
moves sehen und letzten endes ist das thema ja ein sehr langfristiges weil wir werden uns mit diesem problem noch lange rumschlagen und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass wir hier sowohl im bereich kooperation mit plattformen anbietern die diskussion mit apple.
So ein beispiel sehen werden dass dass diese funktionalitäten vielleicht auch kurzfristig nachgereicht werden die einfach um so ein szenario zu ermöglichen dann auch benötigt werden.
Gut mach mal weiter wie es auch schlecht laufen kann sieht man jetzt auch schon in anderen ländern haben da zum beispiel den fall in polen.
Da gibt's nämlich eine app.
Die zwar jetzt nicht das tut was wir jetzt hier besprochen haben dieses tracing sondern da geht's eigentlich eher um konkrete individualle überwachung von leuten die in quarantäne gesteckt werden,
konkret gold nämlich dort eine app die zum einsatz kommt in dem moment wo leute aus dem ausland wieder nach polen zurückkommen und dann erstmal quarantäne werden weil war ja im ausland und die dann eben zwei wochen zu hause sein müssen,
und ja dann werden die leute quasi vor die wahl gestellt also entweder reiten jetzt bei dir da regelmäßig die bullen ein um zu gucken ob du auch wirklich in quarantäne bist,
oder kannst du hier mal diese app runterladen dann okay alles klar nämlich halt die app was müssen sie dann tun die app kommt dann irgendwie mehrmals täglich auf einen zu und sagt hallo ich bin's deine quarantäne app.
Und du hast jetzt mal zwanzig minuten zeit hier ein selfie aufzunehmen.
Und das wird dann hochgeladen und das guckt sich dann jemand an und wenn du irgendwie nicht in zwanzig minuten hier reagierst dann gibt's noch irgendwie eine warnung und ab dann werden auch bußgelder fällig,
und nicht zu knapp und aus diesem foto was du dann machst muss halt in irgendeiner form ersichtlich sein dass du immer noch an demselben ort bist mit dem du anfangs dich hier mal eingecheckt hast.
Ähnliches wird übrigens aus.
Hongkong und taiwan berichtet ich bin mir also da nochmal das ist jetzt vorsichtig wir haben ja extra hier so ein checker verlinkt dass es in polen tatsächlich so ist wo es also auch mit surprise videocalls geht
und das bedeutet dass dein handy zu einer.
Digitalen fußfessel wird also nichts anderes womit man.
Irgendwie straftäter zur an ihr zuhause bindet und.
Das ist die der fantasie sind keine grenzen gesetzt wenn es darum geht dir irgendwelche grenzen zu setzen.
Und das ist.
Das ist schon echt übel und deswegen ist das eben auch so ein thema wo man drauf achten muss.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich auch eine zeit in der viel kommuniziert werden muss und wie schön dass wir das internet haben.
Und all die ganzen tollen werkzeuge nicht nur um hier zu quarantäne selfies zu machen entweder um sich bei der polizei zu melden oder über seinen freunden oder um zu zeigen was für eine geile maske man sich jetzt genäht hat.
Vor allem sind ja videokonferenzen der hit.
Und da ist so eine app gerade in aller munde und auch auf aller leute screens nämlich das von der firma summe.
Wird von vielen verwendet ne.
Hat tatsächlich ist das ist die die geheime corona app eigentlich ne weil das habe ich es haben nicht so viele menschen genutzt.
Zoom.
Muss man jetzt dazu sagen wird von vielen verwendet weil es tatsächlich eine der am besten funktionierenden.
Videokonferenz applikationen ist das haben sie zum beispiel oder das hat leim unter beweis gestellt dieser
elektroroller hersteller die haben nämlich ich glaube vierhundert sechs personen in einer summe konferenz gefeuert,
vierhundertsechs personen musst du erst mal in eine videokonferenz kriegen da ist also die die leistungsfähigkeit von zoom.
Unter beweis gestellt worden leider leider leider also ich habe dieses zoom ohnehin niemals auf meinem rechner installiert weil es letztes jahr schon,
meldungen darüber gab dass das ding irgend so einen komischen port lokal bei dir aufgemacht hat also einen service auf deinem rechner hat laufen lassen
der irgendwie dabei helfen sollte zoom-konferenz links zu öffnen der noch dazu eine schwachstelle hatte und der drittens von deinem rechner noch nicht mal ins installiert wurde wenn du die scheiß app installiert hast
seitdem war schon klar dass das auf meinen rechnern so schnell nicht laufen wird.
Aber linus das war doch nur für die benutzbar seit der der app und dass dass dass du schneller an deine app reinkommst wenn du sie brauchst wenn ich mal anruft.
Und andere eben auch ja,
also so hat jetzt sehr viel aufmerksamkeit bekommen erstens wir wollen das jetzt mal nur kurz zusammenfassen also der vier im hintergrund ist unklar
die haben irgendwelche chinesischen unternehmen damit drin weiß der geier wer das alles da hochschießt dann hatten sie
verstöße gegen ihre eigene datenschutzerklärung haben nämlich facebook tracking
irgendwie gemacht selbst wenn du nicht bei facebook warst dann hatten sie verstöße gegen ihre eigenen versprechen weil die verschlüsselung nicht so ist wie sie beschrieben ist hatten irgendwie halb so lange kies wie behauptet am ende zu ende verschlüsselung behauptet in fällen wo
gar kein ende zu ende-verschlüsselung stattfinden und so weiter dann gab es einen regen an praktisch relevanten schwachstellen wo du,
zum beispiel leuten die nachricht schicken konntest um dann letztendlich code execution auf ihren rechnern zu bekommen dann hat ein ehemaliger mitarbeiter mal kurz zwei siro days gedroppt und
ich kann nur sagen das ende ist hier noch nicht erreicht.
Es wurde dann noch ein zoom gezeigt wo also weißt du du du rufst einfach im prinzip automatisiert,
crowd so quasi zum conference das,
ist dann insbesondere interessant geworden nachdem boris johnson irgendeine zoom-konferenz gefilmt hat wo oben die meeting-id stand und die war nicht passwort geschützt also konnte man einfach rein,
mit diesem zoom kriegst du in einer stunde einhundert ungeschützten konferenzen mit anderen worten es gibt ein neues hobby,
nämlich zum roulette kennst du noch chatroulette.
Hier.
Kannst du dich sozusagen in beliebige government krisensitzung einfach.
Kommt.
Rein entblößen.
Also so ein bisschen krisen tinder krisen tinder via zoom und.
Ja also ich kenne da die eine oder anderen blick der sich dann noch mit anderen sachen dieser dieser zoom-app auseinandersetzt da wird noch einiges kommen.
Und.
Ja das das zeigt halt mal wieder ne wenn man sich wenn man sich um so eine digitalisierung früher kümmert dann,
man muss man eben in der not nicht auf einmal fliegen fressen was hier jetzt leider der fall zu sein scheint.
Also da kommt noch was das hat sie noch nicht ausgesucht und ich würde.
Jetzt generell eben dabei bleiben das nur mit sagen wir mal so das würde ich nur auf den auf den firmenrechner verwenden.
Ja digitalen hat in der krise so einige stolperfallen aufgestellt das sehen wir schon.
Jetzt wollte ich nochmal eine kleine andere sache zitieren die in einer studie vor kurzem veröffentlicht wurde womit man überhaupt nicht gerechnet hat jetzt haben wir ja gerade so eine phase in der es extrem wichtig ist,
die forschung an dieser ganzen viren situation enorm voran kommt und da ist natürlich vor allem wichtig dass der wissenschaftliche austausch
wunderbar funktioniert in form von studien und zahlen und belegen und natürlich müssen auch diese ganzen
studien überprüft werden können nachvollzogen werden können das ist schon immer wichtig gewesen,
aber lange lange zeit hat man das problem dass eben auch oft mit studien die passenden.
Daten nicht so richtig veröffentlicht wurden da wurde dann halt so ein bisschen aufstellung gemacht na ja wir haben da mal so gemessen etcetera in den letzten jahren ist es dann doch
zunehmenden maße usus geworden an seine studien auch daten
richtig anzuhängen also dass man eben auch wirklich herunterladbaren dateien hat indem dann entsprechende aufstellung zu finden war die man sich herunterladen konnte wo man dann eben auch entsprechend
studien nachvollziehen konnte das hat noch eine ganze latte von anderen problemen bei messmethoden geräte kalibras et cetera also je nachdem wohin man schaut gibt's da verschiedenartige probleme aber es gibt so ein ganz konkretes extrem vermeidbar
problem auf eine bestimmte art und weise ganz speziell in
der genfer basierten forschung und da gehört natürlich diese viren auch mit dazu weil wir haben es hier mit den anderen gehen
zu tun die hier klar erkannt werden müssen et cetera woran geforscht wird hat der virus mutiert etcetera und nun hat eine studie sich mal
die daten angeschaut,
die nun an diesem wissenschaftlichen studien denn so dranhängen hat sich da verschiedene journals genommen und eine größere teilmenge von papern überprüft das war dann irgendwie sowas wie größenordnung von,
knapp zweitausendsechshundert studien den dann in der summe fünfunddreißigtausend tabellen anhängen.
In denen sich gen listen befanden und da muss man jetzt so wissen so gene haben halt so spezielle identify,
je nachdem welchem system man sich da befindet gibt es dann halt
so bezeichnungen wie was weiß ich vier buchstaben und eine zahl oder auch längere buchstaben ketten also sind sozusagen buchstaben und zahlen ketten
die hier in tabellen angehalten sind um einfach bestimmte gene oder eben auch andere moleküle verschiedene biologische identify
drin zu haben und,
das ist natürlich insofern ganz sportlich als das jetzt eine großzahl dieser,
tabellen dann im excel format vorgehalten werden das heißt es gibt dann so lange lange listen wo diese ganzen gene aufgezählt sind
und mit entsprechenden messwerten versehen werden etcetera je nachdem was in dieser studie dann relevant war.
Und man hat dann halt so eine spalte da stehen dann diese ganzen gen namen drin tja das problem ist jetzt dass excel,
eine nicht abschaltbar are funktion hat in der halt eingaben in solchen feldern.
Ich sage mal intelligent interpretiert werden
das heißt selbst wenn diese daten eingelesen werden aus einer datei aktiviert sich so eine funktion die halt so schaut so okay was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich oder es kann auch eben zum zeitpunkt der eingabe oder bei copy paste stattfinden.
Und jetzt gibt es so gehen symbole wie zum beispiel zwei.
Ja oder c eins und wer sich das mal so ein bisschen mit der englischen sprache im hinterkopf anhört wird schon merken so,
liest sich so ähnlich wie so ein wie so ein monatsname,
und das denkt sich dann excel halt auch und wenn er so ein zwei steht dann ist halt in einigen fällen wird es einfach ersetzt und dann steht da halt zwei strich,
sepp war das ganze einfach als zweiter september kenne ich kann ich dir besser hinschreiben kein problem ich mache das mal für dich und aus einem marsch eins wird halt schnell mal der erste märz et cetera.
Also solche datums konversion dass das eine anderes problem sind so sachen es gibt so identify.
In der studie wurde von den risiken die feiern,
biologischer standard gesprochen da sind dann oft so zahlen drin wo dann am ende buchstabe und nochmal eine zahl steht dann kann es halt sein dass du so ein feld hast wie zwo drei eins null null null neun dreizehn.
Und dann kommt halt excel und sagt so kenne ich exponentielle darstellung und macht dann halt
daraus eine zwo komma eins plus dreizehn exponentielle zahlen darstellung missinterpretiert also etwas was eigentlich eins dringend ist und was unveränderlich sein soll und schreibt doch einfach mal eine zahl rein.
Ja aber tim darf ich dabei ernsthaft fragen also in das ist ja jetzt.
Schon üblich dass man insbesondere im rahmen der datenverarbeitung jedes feld.
Oder im rahmen der programmierung jede variable dem korrekten typ zuordnen muss und
wenn hier leute einfach irgendwas eingeben kann mir auch vorstellen dass excel eben versucht zu unterstützen aber dürfte es nicht einfach zu lösen sein indem man die spalte markiert und sagt das ist eins dringend,
also so löse ich das ich kenne das ja auch wenn ich hier bei meinen genetischen big data studien ab und zu mal paar sachen ein tippe das excellencemind klüger zu sein als ich aber ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen dass das sich nicht abschalten lässt.
Es kann durchaus sein dass das ein lösbarer problem ist auf einer konfigurations basis tatsache ist ja mal diese ganzen studien durchsucht und haben halt mal geguckt was denn wo eigentlich drin steht wo gehen listen sind und haben die dann einfach manuell überprüft und hatten in neunzehn komma sechs prozent
aller dateien entsprechende fehler gefunden.
Okay wohnwände aber dann auch irgendwelche hatte das konsequenzen für die ergebnisse oder war das jetzt immer nur hier die die also wurde jetzt auf einmal irgendwann auch damit gerechnet oder ist es letztendlich immer nur labels die falsch waren.
Es entgehen listen es sind sozusagen ketten von genen die dann eben spezifische viren oder was auch immer in den studien jeweils betrachtet wurde
konkret beschrieben haben das sind quasi die daten das sind die die die weiter gegebenen wissenschaftlichen informationen die sich dann aber während der weitergabe durch eben diese modifikation durch diese auto korrekt funktion von excel entsprechend geändert haben ohne dass es dann eben denjenigen aufgefallen ist
die diese daten veröffentlicht haben und damit für
führt es halt einfach mal de facto da kann man jetzt tausend mal sagen ja hätte hätte fahrradkette tatsache ist dabei sind einfach extrem viele fehler drin gewesen.
Die relevante information ist dann fehlerhaft und offenbar hat keiner gemerkt und,
die die die die publikation dann sehen trauen sie nicht mehr zu fragen was denn das gehen alle zwei punkt einunddreißig plus dreizehn ist und wenn sie danach suchen finden sie neunhundert
achtzig andere studien die es erwähnen und dann trauen sich erst recht nicht mehr zu fragen.
Genau was auch noch auffiel war umso renommierter die journals waren umso höher war die fehlerquote weil halt bei renommierten journals die anforderungen für diese anhänger noch höher sind das heißt sie hatten mehr anhänger und da hat sich dann entsprechend die fehlerquote ordner erhöht
und um es noch richtig beunruhigend zu machen sie haben sich dann eben die studien auch mal so im verlauf der zeit angeschaut,
und haben halt festgestellt dass die fehlerrate sich in den letzten jahren auch immer noch weiter gesteigert hat also umso jünger diese studien sind umso höher ist diese fehlerrate weil eben noch mehr,
in anführungsstrichen moderne tools zum,
einsatz kommen das paper meint auch noch bisher gibt es keine möglichkeit diese automatische conversion in excel
oder auch in anderen sprit programmes betrifft nicht nur excel so auch libero office kalk apatsche open office kalk et cetera abzuschalten
sie weisen allerdings noch darauf hin dass sie das problem interessanterweise in google,
schieß also in der online variante von google nicht gehabt haben wenn sie da copy-paste gemacht haben und wenn sie dann.
Die von google steht abgespeicherten sachen wiederum in excel reingeworfen haben wurde dort entsprechend dann das datenmaterial entsprechend markiert das
eben dann auch mit excel diese probleme nicht mehr bestanden also es ist sozusagen ein etwas was im prozess,
im einsatz dieser tools stattfinden kann weil dort eine funktion getriggert wird die eben nicht abschaltbar ist und es gibt
durchaus wege wo das nicht passiert aber de facto passiert ist halt einfach und das können sie eben anhand ihrer studie ganz klar mit zahlen belegen dass wir da so ein problem haben dass man nochmal so als ganz genereller hinweis sollten uns irgendwelche wissenschaftler hier zuhören und so weiter
tools check ja haben wir noch luft für ein bisschen sonstige,
gronau panik vielleicht noch ein kurzer hinweis wir haben ja jetzt auch gerade das problem.
Dass die parlamente genauso dem kontakt verbot unterliegen
und so ein bisschen das problem haben das zu tun was ihr halt normalerweise tun nämlich miteinander zu reden im parlament sprich versammlung im parlament selber sind problematisch und damit natürlich auch die.
Abstimmung die da normalerweise stattfinden und man fragt sich natürlich jetzt wie kann es denn jetzt hier weitergehen.
Ähnliches problem haben wir natürlich jetzt auch bei kommenden parteitagen oder sonstigen abstimmungsergebnisses die grünen haben jetzt auch glaube ich gerade angekündigt dass sie jetzt einen parteitag machen explizit,
konkret zur eben cobic krise,
wir haben allerdings auch darauf hingewiesen dass alle abstimmungen die dort gemacht werden nicht geheimer natur sind sondern es nur um offene abstimmung geht und planen das ganze jetzt digital komplett durchzuziehen das wird sicherlich sportlich glaube das findet so in einem monat statt
aber das problem besteht natürlich insbesondere auch im eu-parlament dort hat man nämlich jetzt beschlossen dass man vorübergehend erstmal per e-mail abstimmt,
was nach einer richtig geilen idee klingt spricht wenn die,
abstimmung stattfinden oder sozusagen die jeweiligen gesetzesvorhaben besprochen werden.
Dann wird zeitnah den leuten ein abstimmungs formular per e-mail zugesendet was sie dann ausgefüllte bitte wieder zurücksenden sollen aber natürlich nur von dem offiziellen e-mail-account des oder der abgeordneten.
Und der ganze umlauf soll sich also so im minutenbereich abspielen also es ist nicht so mit ja schick mir meinen nächsten montag oder so sondern es ist relativ kurzfristig trotzdem gibt's halt dort keinen anderen mechanismus als
e-mail
bisschen unklar aus der berichts- lage ist für mich ob hier in irgendeiner form eine elektronische signierung überhaupt zum einsatz kommt ich weiß gar nicht ob sowas überhaupt existiert also ob sowas sich bewusst also sowas existiert natürlich theoretisch aber praktisch weiß ich nicht
hier entsprechende signierung zum beispiel zum einsatz kommt bei bei der eu wünschenswert wäre das natürlich sowieso.
Und mir ist auch nicht ganz klar
was sie damit meinen mit e-mail ob das jetzt sozusagen bedeutet dass das eben ausschließlich e-mail ist die über so einen eu intranet und system vielleicht
laufen muss oder ob wir hier tatsächlich über e-mail die über normale internet server übertragen wird handelt
ist natürlich jetzt ein generelles problem und was natürlich auch zu befürchten besteht ist jetzt so wenn das so weitergeht.
Wie wird dann überhaupt noch gewählt da sehe ich natürlich die nächste wahl computer debatte schon wieder am horizont,
glühen.
Spätestens in den usa spielt das denn jetzt sehr zügig eine rolle ne.
Oh ja genau machen wir das doch einfach mal online hier oh trump wurde wieder gewählt zu prise wie konnte das denn passieren.
So damit wären wir dann fast am ende am ende kommen unsere termine denn es gibt einen und zwar nächste woche.
Denn nächste woche ist ja ostern aber aufgrund der kontaktverbot e musste,
das ist das heck abgesagt werden was in hamburg hätte stattfinden sollen und das hat das volk,
zum anlass genommen mal anfangen zu üben eine veranstaltung komplett remote durchzuziehen,
also mit vortragenden von zuhause live-streams mit chat räumen um sich darüber auszutauschen das ganze hat den titel hidden service,
es ist ein digital verteiltes online- chaos und,
es gibt natürlich auch organist sessions zum kuratierten programm und wahrscheinlich am ende dann einen sehr interessanten infrastructure review die teilnahme ist sogar kostenlos.
Und das programm gibt's am elften zwölften april wir media punkt c,
punkt de hoffen wir mal dass wir diese wunderbare technik nicht allzu oft und allzu lange brauchen werden und solange wir das tun er freuen wir uns daran.
Also ehrlich gesagt das kann schon noch eine weile dauern also in gewisser hinsicht haben wir mit dem chaos communication kongress am ende des jahres.
Wir haben hier in logbuch netzpolitik das problem dass wir eine ganze menge probleme an die wand malen die üblicherweise eintreten.
Da hast du recht.
Insofern wollte ich dann noch an am ende der sendung danken und zwar stefan,
dominik samuel und einer unbekannten person der name bei mir nicht angekommen ist und einige von euch merken dass sie vielleicht in dieser liste noch fehlen weil ich auch gerade an ihre daten nicht komme
aber ihr kennt ja unsere sendung zum csd zwei problem dass ich vielleicht irgendwann wieder lösen werde.
Hallo.
Tja linus wann werden wir uns wiedersehen wir wissen's nicht.
Es war tatsächlich nicht ne aber kriegen wir schon irgendwann hin ich komme ich komme heute abend vorbei.
Okay dann sag mal genau wann dann kann ich schnell fliehen der abstand halten ganz wichtig.
Das war bei bei lanz tatsächlich so ein bisschen das ding das alle die da waren sagten so boys bin erste mal wieder vor der tür gewesen seit längerer zeit ne.
War bestimmt ganz entspannend irgendwie ein bisschen reisen und so.
Also ich sage mal so ein ice wenn ihr den ganzen waggon für dich hast dann ist er auch halbwegs erträglich keine kinder die fangen spielen.
Ruhe abteil wird respektiert von allen die drin sitzen nämlich mir.
Und das war nicht alles schlecht ich sage nur es war nicht alles schlecht.
Handyempfang war der auch besser.
Hab ich nicht probiert also so einige sachen da man will ja auch.
Hättest du mal die ganzen datenmengen für dich alleine gehabt hätte richtig saugen können saugen ja meine ich doch meine ich doch.
Nein aber telefonieren habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ach so wer telefonieren schon noch da kann man so richtig schön von berlin nach hamburg einmal die richtig durch netflixen ist doch mal was aber wahrscheinlich war es gedrosselt ne.
Quatsch das wlan macht doch trotzdem nach zehn bmw dicht oder wann.
Leute bleibt heiter und ja.
Wir bleiben weiter hier dran an den ganzen netz
politischen themen kleiner werbeblock noch für meinen zweitkanal ukw wo ich in schnellerer folge versuche unterschiedliche aspekte der aktuellen situation,
zu beleuchten sehr unterschiedliche themen lage hat auch eine lange liste was ich abklappern will aber sonst nichts zu tun wer also lust hat kann da auch mal reinhören ukw punkt fm.
Ja und wir bleiben aber erstmal so ist nicht weiter sondersendung bedarf gibt bei unserem wochenprogramm hier.
So machen wir das alles klar bis dann tschüss.
Tschau tschau.